how old were you when you went to the
comedy club with your friends and they
said hey you're a funny guy you should
get up there and do something that's 21.
21 yeah that's a late start really it is
yeah comedy was banned in south africa
because of apartheid no [ __ ] yeah it's
the same reason like sugar man was bad
like music was certain music was banned
and comedy was banned no free speech
like do you have any sense of like even
classic rock is that all new to you now
because growing up like you weren't
exposed to the stones no we had like a
an explosion of infamous you can imagine
we were basically like like amish people
in a way yeah and then like all of a
sudden democracy hits and i was like
boom what you guys know about hip-hop
and then you became a dj didn't you yeah
i did you were a disc jockey i loved it
but by diss track i mean you'd go to
parties and spin records i also did like
a certain vibe of what you did you were
on the radio i was on the radio
when you were doing that i was doing
radio before so i was doing radio when i
was 20. what the [ __ ] did you get on the
radio you weren't famous you hadn't
tried stand-up comedy it was it was so
there was a radio station that was
having like a rev i don't even know how
i heard about this i just hustled my
whole life so i i heard that there was a
radio station that they said they were
doing they were getting new djs they
were and then i was like i should just
try and go for this job i was like let
me see what you had balls
yeah but it's not even balls it's
desperation it's like you had no money
i'm allergic to being broke that's my
thing so so that's your that's your your
core value i will i don't know
i will always find a way to work i i
read this about you that when you were
in school because you were fast you
would get on the cafeteria line quickly
and charge people money to stand in line
for them right so at my school the way
it worked is a hustler yeah the way it
worked for us is we had what was called
assembly and then after assembly
immediately you could go to recess to
the cafeteria but now the food would get
finished so the quicker you could get to
the cafeteria the better chances you had
of getting the food that you wanted and
so i was one of the fastest kids in
school so what i would do is i also had
no shame and no ladies were coming after
me so as soon as assembly would break i
would sprint it was a good like 20 30
seconds of running through the entire
school and we have big schools in south
africa like running through the school
to get to the cafeteria and i was always
first in line but then i had like no
money i'd just buy like one thing right
and no lunch money yeah and then what
happened is one day one of the other
kids found me at the front of the line
they were like hey can you buy that for
me and then they said out of the
evolution they're like i'll give you two
bucks i'll give you five bucks extra and
i was like wait
this is a business you'll pay me because
i'm at the front of the line
and then and then i started saying to
people instead of finding me at the
front of the line
why not just pay me before you you pay
me meet me you give me your orders and
then i will order and so i would order
every day for about five to seven kids
and you had a nice little income from
that and that's how i made my pocket
money yeah so you're not kidding around
when when you say hey i cannot be broke
i'm always going to find a way to work
you went from standing online for people
to dj business being on the radio but at
21 when you go up and you've given no
kind of thought about being a comic and
you go up on stage you were funny yeah
and what do you what did you
but you have no jokes
right i mean there's nothing i i had the
same thing i have now which is just life
and stories about what i'm experiencing
and what did you talk about when you
went i talked about
my so i i had nigerian friends who ran a
pawn shop that also doubled as a um
like a drug business
and i talked about their shop and like
just how we used to hang out
and and do impressions of these yeah and
i would just do impressions of them and
the way they would talk to me and and
you know and then i would talk about
like what was happening in south africa
it just it came together yeah it just
came and my friends would tell me they'd
be like yo you should tell that story
did the light bulb turn on over your
head and go oh this is what i'm gonna do
now i'm gonna go up on stage and talk
about my life because it went so well
the first night well i was really lucky
the comedians were there told me that
they had the light bulb oh no kidding
yeah like you might not have been i got
off stage and i was like wow that was
fun right and then they came and said
you're a stand-up comedian i said no no
i work on radio they said no you're a
stand-up comedian you need to do this
wow i'm eternally grateful to them
because i that's what i did